make others look good make other people
look good and you will do well it's not
about kissing ass it's about making
someone look good it's about providing
the support so that others can be good
clear the path to the people above you
and you will eventually create a path
for yourself there's an old saying say
little do much imagine it for every
person you met you thought of some way
to help them something you could do for
them and you looked at it in a way that
entirely benefited them and not you the
cumulative effect this would have over
time would be profound you learn a great
deal by solving diverse problems develop
a reputation for being indispensable you
have countless new relationships you'd
have an enormous Bank of favors to call
upon down the road help yourself by
helping others make a concerted effort
to trade your short-term gratification
for longer-term payoff whereas everyone
else wants to get the credit and be
respected you can forget credit you can
forget it so hard that you're glad when
others get it instead of you that was
your aim after all let the others take
credit on credit while you defer and
earn interest on the principal if you
pick up this mantle once you'll see what
most people's egos prevent them from
appreciating the person who clears the
path ultimately controls its direction
you